welcome back let's return to the
extinction rebellion protests which
blocked roads outside the printing press
is owned by rupert murdoch
the news corp sites in brooksburg
hertfordshire and merseyside produced
copies of several national papers
campaigners said they wanted to prevent
titles including the sun
the times and the daily mail from
reaching shops today we can speak now to
donica
mccarthy an environmental author and a
spokesperson for extinction rebellion
donica welcome to you thanks for taking
the time to speak to us
what's the target of this action the
content of the newspapers and their
coverage of climate change
or the owners of the newspapers
we would like the we basically want the
owners and the senior editors
to take the climate change seriously at
the moment there is
rank complacency among the client the uh
the media and among the government and
so we feel that we had to come here
today to do a radical dramatic action
to get to challenge that complacency the
un said
we have to radically cut carbon
emissions by the end of 2020. that's in
five months time
and the government instead of doing that
investing hundreds of billions of pounds
in an old dirty quantitative easing
program
okay leaving the government aside
because we're talking about the press
and the specific action and
you say that they're not basically
taking it seriously just looking around
today i mean you'll probably be aware by
now that sir david attenborough had a
big piece in the sun
saying that he believes the planet can
be saved from global warming
and here is how to do so looking at the
time zone pages
a full page of coverage on climate
change as well as historical articles
the telegraph's own environmental
reporter
tweeting i have a big environment
investigation i've been working very
hard
on in the paper but it's now been held
because extinction rebellion have become
the story disappointed doesn't cover it
there are journalists trying to cover
what you've now suppressed
yeah all of the major papers may have an
environmental journalist
and so there may be the occasional
article that david attenborough but if
you look at the rest of the sum
they run a campaign to promote fracking
across britain they've staged
false fracking protests they have run a
campaign to cut taxes on fossil fuels
for 10 years
that has taken 110 billion pounds out of
the nhs and the
the government coffers that could have
been invested in a green new deal
and so therefore the overwhelming
coverage in in the murdoch's paper
and the billionaire press is
anti-climate action anti-investment in a
green new deal
across the world murdoch is is
recognized as an impediment to climate
action
his own son james has quit news core
over the issue
and so what we are saying today is we
want those five tax haven billionaires
to ensure their corporations take this
seriously and help protect britain
do you support i mean you clearly do
support the method of doing so but you
seem to have managed to unite
very different parts of the political
spectrum against what you've done today
i mean obviously the home secretary
pretty patel has criticized what you've
done
the labor um shadow minister
for the in culture media and sport has
said a free press is vital for our
democracy
people have the right to read what they
want stopping them from being
distributed and printers from doing
their jobs is wrong
even the leader one of the leaders of
reporters without borders the
international ngo
for press freedom has said there is this
is a clear danger in reducing media
plurality
and restricting access to information i
mean you're managing to
to to garner a lot of criticism from
people whose support you need
well the idea that britain has a diverse
press is a joke
over 70 to 80 percent of our media is
owned by five people
who are they they live offshore in tax
havens how
the idea that britain has a diverse
media is farcical
or every single election for the last 45
years
has been the prime minister has been
backed by rupert murdoch
but what do you think is reduced he's
reduced that diversity
what you've done today is reduced that
diversity even further in terms of the
choice people have today on their
newsstand
that's absolutely untrue what we were
actually saying for the last 45 years
murdoch and rothermere and the barclay
brothers have been heard
over above everybody else in this
country it is time for just one day
that those of us who passionately
believe that britain is under threat
of extreme danger according to un should
be heard and that's why we've come today
because that complacency
by those five men is a threat to bret
threat to britain
however they still print um extinction
rebellions own views
gail bradbook one of your co-founders
only 24 hours ago had a piece in the
evening standard
one of the action one of the targets of
your action
the the idea that you have one article
from gail bradford an interview and then
20 pages on
cruises flights meat eating um
consumption consumerism
our entire press creates the com the
permission for a high carbon lifestyle
and doesn't move us towards where we
need to be what we are here today is
saying is
the media is acting as chamberlain at
the delaying action to 2050
and what we need is a churchillian
action to death britain and the natural
world we've lost 83 percent of nature
and the government has announced
planning system that will destroy more
of nature
we by the time i die we may have lost
all of nature that was on the planet
when i was born this is the christ and
that's why we're here today
donald mccarthy uh thank you very much
indeed for your time appreciate it today
i'll speak to you again
i imagine very soon because there's 10
days of protests
from extinction rebellion that are
taking place at the moment that as uh
you will have seen coverage of on sky
news